there is an emergency unfolding in the
maasai mara
the annual wildebeest migration
one of the animal kingdom's most
spectacular sights
is stalling
and it's because of climate change
hundreds of thousands should be
migrating over the plains of the
serengeti to feast on the mara's lush
green grass
but the rains have failed most of the
giant herds are still across the border
in tanzania uncertain of finding fresh
pasture
if the rains don't come
the wildebeest don't come and that
impacts the entire mara ecosystem
everything including man and animal
the masai mara is in danger of becoming
unbalanced hello how are you good good
good
saitoti silentoi is a maasai born and
raised here in the mara it is usually an
endless mass of black you know but over
the last few years yeah it has been very
regular
he tells me the entire food chain is
under threat
the annual world-based migration provide
a very vital they play a very vital role
uh in the maasai mara because
you know they bring that you know that
bulk food that the predators need so if
you cut down this uh
main
source of food then basically you you
know the predators won't make it you
know especially the lions and the hyenas
and that is why saitoti has this grim
warning if no agent action is done like
right now to cap the the effects of
climate change then yeah we will
definitely lose the matter
the mauro river should be flowing fast
and free but you can see just how low
the water levels are
the failed rains mean the mars grazing
animals are pushed to look outside the
reserve for food
[Music]
the maasai are also being forced to find
new pastures for their cattle
increasing human animal conflict adding
more pressure to a way of life under
threat from global warming
so as we talk we have a big big problem
between human life yeah
and
wild animals as well
jackson raqqa is a maasai herder as a
boy he remembers regular rains but says
it has all changed
if there's no rain soon we are going to
lose a big big number of cows which is a
problem to us
understand you can do about it
so we are just just praying so hard for
the rain to come
the cycle of life and death looks brutal
but it's nature's way of keeping the
balance
but the animals here are powerless to
stop the drivers for climate change
their survival
very much depends
on man
ashish joshi at the masai mara in kenya